how's it going everyone welcome to
cringe Thursday
[Music]
cringe what day is it Oh Thursday this
week's tea comes from Trisha Paytas I'm
about five weeks late on this it was one
of those things where you see in your
peripheral you like I don't really care
about that but then the more you look
into it you're like Jesus Christ at the
full block and that's about it
with Trisha Paytas and Sally I couldn't
be a Teletubby but you know what I
became one he/she might be a lot of
things
Teletubby is not one of them liar
manipulator playing victim aggressive
abusive not a Teletubby so what has she
done recently well a couple things
two things I knew about Trisha from this
god forbid and video called showering
with my boyfriend whatever you do do not
watch this video it's a cursed video I
don't know buddy
just don't watch this video
me with my sleep paralysis to whoever
was the cameraman we send a deeper
Trisha has been wheezing her way in in
different ways where I hope that would
never see her again after that video
she's been part of the david dobrik
vlogs she's been doing her regulars feel
of crying almost as good as me crying in
my car there recently she got there in a
bit the drama with Nick although I would
called though do you want to lose some
brain cells great keep watching you see
Trisha Paytas had the competition for
who would make a cover of her song and
Nicole called me the beautiful song
it's actually not bad I didn't know you
had any other talent but crying about
who God knows what while eating did you
send a hotel room when you give up on
your talent and dreams mukbang yeah
Trisha saw this cover that Nicole diver
called the death of her video and she be
like I have loved you for so long as a
fan and this blew my mind when I saw it
in the subscription so she was
subscribed even we need to get together
in person there is something about you
and then this I'm speechless
truly I can't think of the right words
to say and then she tweets him going
like hey babe where do you live we need
to call them love is a pair you're never
brought tears TM what relevance does
this have to anything Felix well I'll
have you know that Trisha invited him to
collab he flew all the way from Colombia
and she just ghosted him uh-huh
okay so Trisha Paytas right now I've
been watching you for a few months I
just adore you I don't know if you've
seen my videos about not one to be vegan
anymore but it would be so fun to eat
something non vegan with you she respond
hell yeah
actually I'm pretty free next week what
day are you thinking I said I'm free on
next week - I just do YouTube that's a
super flexible so you can pick the day
I'm looking at flights now so I let her
know I'm flying I said I'm looking at
the flights I'll let her know
are you available but she says I'm free
all week I said I've never been to
California before the best flight deal
is Tuesday the 17th then she responds I
can make that work I can make that work
hi Trisha I came to LA to see ya but I
don't know how to get a whole yeah
is everything okay next one says if I
did something wrong he let me know I
have gifts from you from Colombia he
brought gifts from Colombia this is
opposed to be cringe we're getting into
the cringe the cringe is bad area if it
has meaning behind it
okay but the best part about this is
that even though Trisha clearly publicly
said that she subscribed to him watch
his videos and wanted to collab with him
on mine there's a different story
[Music]
I was never going to I wasn't gonna like
collab you heard a meanie I don't know
where that came from your text message
where that come from
and I was like they were all like Trisha
goes to him I was like Trisha didn't
even know that he was coming no idea no
idea no I dad don't like all that the
only thing I heard of him wasn't he did
my warrior cover you said you were
subscribed in the comments of that video
the only thing I heard of him was what
he did my warrior brah well I thank you
so many people him and a lot of your
fans want to hear an apology I'm not
sorry I feel like you don't know anyway
anything you really know can you
acknowledge that ghosting him was rude I
don't I don't think it's not really you
know you're messed up big time if Paris
Hilton is the voice of reason I don't
know what you want me to say like I'm
not gonna pawn as this person is like
like you know what I mean like there's
something like a little off here asked
he lied I didn't
I felt harassed by him that was it was
still insane it was so insane it's so
scary to me so then she just completely
changed the story because you know
Trisha can't be the bad person the
reason why she goes to him was she was
scared of him that's right because
Naqada avocado had a thumbnail where he
had a knife and said I had enough and
she's just scared of him so now that we
know that she's not a good person it's
okay to make fun of her yeah the next
stop came from H Street Street where I
followed this it was really funny
basically Ethan did a video calling out
the Instagram versus reality subreddit
where you have pictures like this I
actually wanted to make a video in this
my my eye that's too high I'm not
touching that someone's gonna lash out
lo and behold Trisha Paytas saw that
video cuz she was in it I can't even
tell him is any of these Trisha Peters
like honestly cannot help there
why do you why are you even a model if
you're gonna modify your looks that much
it's like from beauty queen to WWF
wrestler in two seconds
you cannot Foix up your heart and soul
remember that this girl tried to use a
face filter on Instagram and her phone
blew up she is the best isn't she not
the best would people even recognize her
if they saw her on the street I mean I
mean to be afraid you probably do this
with almost anyone probably not to the
same extreme but you can take a photo
there's no ugly photos of me however but
over someone else you could take an ugly
photo and then like a BAM photo and be
like yeah this is Coachella verse
throwing down in the McDonald's parking
lot at 3 a.m.
Chella vs. WorldStarHipHop oh that
cannot be the same person to Coachella
versus open-casket funeral so how did
Trish I responded to this video of
course she had the most eloquent
thought-out response that really put
Ethan to place please Allah Cline h3 do
not raise your child to be as ignorant
as your husband I would divorce him ASAP
as he is causing so much damage to young
women
it's basically second act I never been
more disgusted I think that's pretty
fair just tweeting someone's pregnant
wife how to race their child and to
leave their husband Jesus Christ could
you have been any more gross about it I
wasn't gonna say anything but obviously
when people attack ela it's mask off and
I saw her profile pic and I go who was
this rude person I don't recognize her
from her profile picture does anyone
know her she then made a video at 6:00
in the morning sitting on the kitchen
floor hey guys what is up is and then
she even admits to not even having to
watch his video big platform and like
shaving these women like I did
fast-forward to my part I don't really
watch the other people he talked about
Chloe and then right after me Jesus
Christ
I felt like Ethan's video yeah it was
making fun of people obviously that's a
sensitive topic I get it but I think
it's worth criticizing these things
where Instagram has just become this
staple of how people compare themselves
to
look on these insanely retouched photos
or edited photos me like okay why don't
why not look like that when the reality
is actually quite different and I think
that's a lot more damaging than making
fun of it don't need a beep beep like
that Dowell like the reason I post those
ugly photos next to eight pretty photos
wait so she's the one that posed these
photos she's the one that she's the
source other people can't laugh at it
though cuz I do I always want girls to
know that like it's okay to like be like
this
this was Ethan's message as well that's
literally what he said if you had
watched the damn video instead of
lashing out on his wife Jesus Christ
dude
now Trisha Paytas has done some pretty
funny things she said some pretty great
stuff I feel like she does play into the
dumb blonde role like she purposely try
and make her stupid dogs are and are
mammals right yeah dogs are mammals
they're humans or no they're not human
they're part of the animal kingdom that
God created I love you do this that is
an amazing sense yeah dogs are mammals
they're humans dogs are human no they're
not human they're part of the animal
kingdom that God created I love you
Jesus ah but my absolute favorite video
of Trisha Paytas is the Teletubby
breakdown video I love to tell that me
Teletubbies are my
with the other timers are am i where am
i Who am I Trisha Paytas I love to tell
that we Teletubbies are my they are your
what
none need oh my god she actually forgot
but more than my life they saved my life
I think back when I was like 10 just had
not 9 not 11 just 10 just 10 not eight
not seven not six not 40 not 50 not 500
just ten and I wanted to be a Teletubby
nobody Trisha Paytas I wanna be $1 are
they coming and Sally I couldn't be a
Teletubby but you know what this is so
sad
I became one oh okay
I am once hey I'm not stopping yet Jesus
Christ
[Music]
I am a mother he caught up yet I don't
mean that metaphorically I am a literal
towelettes Abby
so she says she wasn't on drugs early
can we applaud my realness baby
communists up la my realness [ __ ] but um
there's some fake-ass youtubers out
there so anyone that says real and fake
is fake anyone says I'm so real other
people are fake they're hundred percent
fake I never if there's no exception to
that rule for those of you the less is
filty and [ __ ] I'm not doing real I
like a [ __ ] talk about everything
like you didn't even knew half the [ __ ]
that these youtubers talk about another
one night you today I genuinely do I
ain't perfect but I love the sub dummies
and I can't
no don't eat it don't do whatever I
can't chew in over my head anymore I
look at this oh my god Trish
do you remember goddamnit
[Music]
okay that is about as much as I can
stomach for cringe Tuesday's that's
stricture paid us everyone I'm sorry for
bringing this to light
I feel like Trisha belongs in this
category of youtubers I just have no
shame it's like the mukbang videos no
one wants to watch those videos you
might say oh well some people like them
sure like what 2% of people that's not
the reason they exist there they're
flashy thumbnail and people are grossed
out by them people don't want to see
that people are outraged about them this
kind of content that no one wants to see
it's kind of content where you're crying
on camera deliberately which I would
never go just whatever it takes to get
views on YouTube there's no shame
whatsoever but Trisha is the exception
of at the same time just being insanely
insecure which is not a good combination
she does have some likeable qualities
though like she's
what you never played super simulator
you know it's fun right I'm not supposed
to give my opinion but give it a try and
then you can tell me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay I'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]